bernard tapie n'est pas salarié de l'om
il sera rémunérée sous forme d'actions
il s'en est longuement expliqué
aujourd'hui dans le passé ces affaires
ont mal tourné même si prochainement il
pourrait récupérer beaucoup d'argent aux
dépens du crédit lyonnais
on le disait ruiné mais vous allez le
voir il n'en est rien françois guillaume
jean marc la lie bernard tapie de retour
sur ses terres en bénévoles le nouveau
manager de l'om ne sera pas rémunéré par
le club phocéen
mais en contrepartie de son travail il
devrait entrer dans le capital de
l'olympique de marseille
pourquoi un tel montage financier retour
quelques années auparavant 31 mars 95
une date clé dans son marathon
judiciaire
ce jour là le tribunal de commerce de
paris
ordonne sa mise en liquidation
judiciaire à titre personnel ses
créanciers lui réclame plus d'un
milliard de francs tapie est
virtuellement ruiné plus le chéquier
plus de cartes de crédit qu tous ses
biens sont saisis et bientôt proposés à
la vente
les créanciers en récolteront 30
millions de francs
son bateau le phocéa est acheté par une
milliardaire libanaise et ce sera tout
son hôtel particulier aurait dû lui
aussi être vendu au moins 100 millions
seulement voilà depuis cinq ans il n'a
pas trouvé preneur
bernard tapie y réside toujours ceux qui
héritent sérieusement les créanciers de
tapis et en premier lieu le cdr
l'organisme public qui a hérité de
toutes les branches pourries du crédit
lyonnais
il faut savoir que il l'a achetée en
empruntant intégralement auprès de l'afd
bo la filiale du crédit lyonnais
la totalité du prix d'acquisition et qui
n'a jamais remboursé 1 franc de cet
emprunt donc aujourd'hui monsieur
bernard tapie débiteurs en liquidation
judiciaire depuis plus de cinq ans vit
dans un hôtel particulier qui n'a jamais
payé et qui ne paye toujours pas et dont
on se demande pourquoi il n'est toujours
pas mise en vente
les avocats du cdr évoque une certaine
inertie dans ce dossier de la part du
liquidateur judiciaire
ce dernier n'a pas souhaité nous parler
devant la caméra la discrétion c'est lui
qui saisit les revenus de bernard tapie
comédiens romancier animateurs en deux
ans selon nos sources l'homme d'affaires
a gagné près de 6 millions de francs
avant impôts il en a reversé un tiers au
liquidateur judiciaire
le montant de son passif aujourd'hui il
est de 800 millions de francs pour se
refaire tapie à une carte dans sa main
adidas il estime avoir été floué par le
crédit lyonnais lors de la vente de
l'entreprise
l'enjeu au moins deux milliards de
francs la justice devrait trancher cette
affaire dans les mois qui viennent et
permettre peut-être à tapis de retrouver
sa splendeur d'antan